all right let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen you know what it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gentlemen welcome back to a very special
edition
today I have a guest and I'm on location
at the Great
Dane Cook's house where he filmed his
latest special and he's on here to talk
about it it's called above it all you
can find it on moments.com Dane Cook and
it's available right now or at Dane Cook
right now and we are filming the podcast
exactly where he shot his special so
this is a great one and I look for for
you guys are seeing it welcome back
[Music]
your world
[Music]
anyways y'all this is a good one so
let's get right to it ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the podcast the
Fantastic mister
ladies and gentlemen
oh yeah this is great good here man yeah
I feel like you're in front of me should
I I should wait I should I should be
right just so we're not like okay yeah
now we're looking at each yeah yeah yeah
I feel good this is good I like your
Oprah cup
I'm rocking Oprah I mean I'm in good
company and then look what I gave you I
gave you my high school graduation Cup
oh wow class of 19. yeah I'm class of
1990 . boom yeah look at us
um okay I'm probably gonna do a
recording thing ahead of time too but
yeah it doesn't matter guys very special
uh
that's the inner voice at the very very
back of your mind it doesn't it doesn't
what am I trying yeah we're doing you
know I had this idea I saw uh welcome to
the podcast for the second time uh the
the Fantastic The Fabulous Mr Dane Cook
my friend and we're at cook tower
and that's and that's that's the that's
a deep cut for the war zone fans that
watch me oh that's right that's right
all the way back for dance Christmas
dance yeah so it was it was cooked tower
for a long time that you never streamed
with me so then it became grif Tower
that's right you know because that's
where I always dropped do people know
why I didn't stream with you yeah
because I I felt like I'm so serious a
competitor that people are gonna be like
where are the yucks in here man but you
know me I'm like I'm gonna be in there
to win but you ever watch online gaming
like that now I feel like I'd I'd fit in
there just did fine it doesn't matter at
this point right now you know what I
mean but I get it you know you know
people are worried about that kind of
stuff I mean you know you're still you
know you don't want to you don't want to
like get it you're about to book a big
movie with like you know what have you
heard yeah
and then at the beginning they go we saw
you on warzone
and so you're not going to get this part
but here we are we we are at this we're
at Dane's house and this is where I live
I do live here and and you did your just
your upcoming special Above It All We
filmed it I this was the stage you're
Stan you were sitting Where I Stood and
performed and he performed with this
beautiful view of Los Angeles this is an
example of like there's nine crimes
happening in real time just look around
you might see a gunshot muzzle
it's like shout out to Ian Edwards Ian
Edwards has a great joke about like you
know when you get to look at those poor
people lights you know laughs
the best you know that's that's the dark
spots
yeah so but here we are and
um I saw the trailer for the special it
looks great it looks really different
and you know so my that's my first
question about this is like did you did
you were you searching for something
different are you at the point of your
career where you felt like the pressure
of doing something different or is it
just like I've been doing this a long
time and I want to do something
different or was it a combination of
both it was it was a combination of both
but
also there was a strong desire after
2019 I do I did Radio City Music Hall
for the first time there was a moment
where I was going to film there and then
somebody told me John Mulaney was
filming his special there and it's kind
of that comic thing of like oh if that
person's doing Red Rocks I'm not gonna
you know I don't want to do my thing
there and so I was like all right well
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna end up doing
that and I was remembering that I moved
into this house 12 years ago and I sat
right here with my brother
and that was probably about a month
before I ended up putting him in prison
for being a bad businessman
we're not going to go we're not go look
at the you know refer to the first time
Dane was on the podcast and get the back
story on that yeah let's get some hits
up on the uh yeah but that wasn't
anything
I sat here with uh my then brother
before I
bought the house and I was like wow you
know I'd love to buy this place I'd only
lived in apartments or out of duffel
bags as Comics know for our whole career
and so he was like you know go for it
you should do it
by rights after that era I was like
probably not financially in a situation
where I could do that and yet once I
once I figured it out and I did move in
and I saved the house I remember
thinking
the the ability to stand here maybe you
know bring a bunch of people in harken
back to Growing Up in Boston where we
would stand on the porch and you would
talk [ __ ] with your neighbors right
right okay this is a a Beantown East
Coast very East Coast thing you gather
around used to not be called roasting it
was called busting chops you get your
neighbors you [ __ ] you know say your
Lawns you know looks terrible and
everybody kind of like your cars too
like everybody kind of bust each other's
chops and if you got laughs you were
kind of like the talk of the
neighborhood that night right it was
like people you'd see people leaving
going man Eric did you got us tonight
and so it was a little bit of like the
Nostalgia of growing up like what
happens when you put me on my porch and
I have a a routine but I also just play
with the people that came to visit and
also just like what comes out of me if
I'm home with the ACT yeah coupled with
what happened with my brother was like
this felt like a uh it felt like almost
like uh something meaningful to go this
represents
uh success failure and then the belief
in yourself to Come Back Against All
Odds so I thought doing it here
that what you said expectation wise for
myself but also I was looking for
something aesthetically different from
what I think maybe I don't know if you
want to get into it like a lot of comedy
shows these days just do not look great
on television yeah I know I know exactly
what you're saying but oh man I'm glad
you got to do your thing here first
because I heard Melanie was going to do
it here
yeah he was scheduled to do it here so
it's good that you got it his pajamas
probably look like a suit I bet he has
like one of those onesies that looks
just like from a distance
um no yeah that that's that's great yeah
you know but you've had so many
different types of specials if you think
about it you know from us from an arena
from Vicious Circle yeah to like that
sort of more dark intimate one at the
Laugh Factory very monochromatic very
like very very One-Shot it was very like
you're reading letters and it was a very
emotional thing to like now now this
yeah and some other ones in between
there yeah and then like this was
something that he was worried about was
like the but you said that this didn't
happen a lot it only happened one time
during the first taping but I had some
lines ready to go if uh Chopper went
overhead like that so it it worked out
I'm just glad there wasn't like a high
speed Pursuit through the hills that
night or I would have been yeah because
I paid for this thing this budget it
came out of my whole pocket so if this
was gonna happen two nights in a row I'd
have the most expensive home video of a
comedy set ever with this yeah but what
if you you had these great jokes ready
for for this and then it never happened
I'd be wanting to have a hello
where's the damn helicopters but but
getting back to what you're saying it
was like you know the the idea that
comedy specials
um the reason my comedy specials were
monochromatic and that that incredible
look that Marty Connor created for
Vicious Circle was I grew up loving the
specials on HBO where people had a set
yeah yeah yeah Carlin had a cemetery
behind him or Robin Williams had like a
a big top or and it matched the theme
and it matched the energy and that's
when it was special yeah and we've lost
a lot of that so Marty Connor directed
this this is the third time I've got got
to work with the legendary Marty culinar
and when I told him what I wanted to do
he's like the first thing he said he
goes drones
I'm like yeah when you think comedy you
think drones so we got some a beautiful
camera package and this is where it
happened this is where it took place
yeah you did you say you did it yourself
I mean that's just how it is right now
but you know you just have more means to
like really do it yourself in a way that
it's like you know you know I mean
because look at this beautiful home man
I mean like I always we talked about
this before I remember from the last
time it's like it's good to be here I
thought of this immediately when I saw
you were doing it at home I was like
well let me come do the podcast here
yeah you know what I mean because it's
just like this is you know what I mean
because this is like it's it's great you
know it's look at this little setup dude
this really set this up at the last
second I mean you're already killing it
on your podcast but this does feel like
we're on like a more traditional kind of
I love it I love it I just I should have
brought my arms but yeah over there just
waiting to like
pipe in a band every time we look over
here we're like right
Rick Glassman comes down on a [ __ ]
yeah he's snapping a lot you know bungee
no but um I don't know man it's like
what do you think what's like what's
next like what more is there well I want
to see more people hopefully in a
situation where with a little bit of
scratch I'm talking about Comics or you
know even young musicians and stuff but
I hope that
doing something like this and we've seen
CK do it we've seen Schultz do it
recently like unbelievably and there's
been other gaffigans and people that
have gone that kind of indie or you know
you know control your own IP but what I
hope that this sets the example of is to
do something and own your content and to
not hand it over to some big streamer or
network that says we got you kid
well it ends up on a splash page for
maybe a day if you're lucky if you're
lucky and then you're like in a position
where you don't ever get to see your
street it's not like this where you know
your streams you can look at your
viewership uh there is no Nielsen rating
data sheet anymore they don't tell you
that stuff Ben Stiller said recently he
can't get his streams for severance ooh
on Apple TV he's like he wants to know
where are they watching who's watching
what age are they in there ah we haven't
printed that out yet and also how many
people are watching they know but they
even knew when they did they even knew
when it wasn't streaming right because
like when Janet Jackson's titty popped
out at the Super Bowl they were like
this is the most dvr'd or whatever that
TiVo at the time we just talk about that
it wasn't a lot of titty there was a big
like doily in the middle yeah yeah what
did we talked some titty around like a
giant figurine that was on her areola
yeah but then
they have these they add these numbers
but you know it's a it's a money thing
like if they tell Ben Stiller hey
wow right actually 50 million people he
leverages a better deal he goes well
then can we get more money for this and
this is
n't that so I
you know it
the business
when does business stop and art begin
and does it ever is it one of those like
what is it Venn diagrams how much of the
circle do you think it really is
um luckily not what do you remember many
many years ago there was like a band uh
TLC broke down like this is how much of
the pie yeah and it was if you've never
seen that video it's really fascinating
I think more of the pie can go to the
artist these days
um if you can have one person that is
investing financially in you if you
can't do your one person to say
it you know if if this wins we cut it
and go our own way or blah blah but if
you can do it independently and I hope
that when this comes out people see this
example of like I get my analytics I get
all the data for a moment the day my
contract ends I get the emails I get the
data I get everything and by the way the
deal's over it's 14 days and my IP is
literally the next day I could sell it
out of my trunk put it on YouTube for
free and that's what I hope that this
ushers in the leasing window on a
streamer might be a great streamer might
have a great
um attraction you know with other movies
the Russo brothers are doing something
we want your thing for three months
let's do a short-term lease together and
then give me my stuff you know what if
what if that comic we won't name names
what if the comic that we know has one
great special and he doesn't or she
doesn't get to do it to that caliber
they're never going to see their uh
royalties mechanical royalties yeah like
a Chase for the rest of their life and
it costs a lot of money to find who has
your money
I know it's weird you say that but I
think that you know you're in a unique
position because you uh you you know you
didn't start in this era you know right
like you do come back and you know it's
weird because you've actually ushered in
a new era because like you know being
the guy on MySpace and realizing you
know what the internet says something we
can use to help us yeah because now the
new era the next iteration of that is
podcasting right you know so like and
and so like if you're a podcaster
let's say like you know Tom Segura you
know your mom's house you know they have
a huge platform so now if he does a
special if he wanted to he could just
put it on your mom's house right and you
you it's already huge and why not I mean
that's his Network that's his I think
it's in this project thing man don't you
think it's a it's a it's a kind of thing
we come from an era where we want this
validation from Mr Hollywood yeah and Mr
Hollywood is HBO it's Netflix it's
showtime it's all these places I will
tell you I promise you this for every
young person that's like pie-eyed and
wants the validation it it does feel
good yeah you do get it and I promise
you five years later you'll be looking
at people like me and going where do I
start to find my the receipts to get
paid what I should be getting paid it's
it's like you got to know the legalese
you got to be able to read that contract
and know okay after this period of time
if I don't have this much that's dude
don't even get me started I have two
special officials out in The Ether
someplace and I I've I email my manager
all the time like yeah yo what's up with
my first special because once show time
once it was done and then like I don't
even know where it is I don't know where
it is or I don't know what's going on
it's it's uh it's mirrored on some
internet site and a little faster or
slower so that they can't pull it for
whatever copyright infraction is
happening all those little tricks that
people do to keep your content on their
page I mean it's crazy and then it's
like uh you ever search yourself and you
see like you're on nine different places
for two nine 2.99 and you're like it's
like
yeah yeah it's like some sort of like
you know this is some breach of contract
Gucci cluji yeah some weird you know
science you just go how'd they get my so
I know exactly what you're saying but
it's again it's how long is it going to
take before you know because then here's
the thing but it also like weirdly even
though you're it's like it's you're
seeking out your residuals but on
another hand if your stuff is that is
permeating that well you're happy that
you're on the road and people are loving
seeing you so you can't be that upset
because you're like I can go out there
right now and do a show now that's the
difference right there because but I
think that that's the reason why say
people right now want a Netflix special
you know because I think like Netflix
did a thing to me where they they
overpaid
for comedy to Corner the market because
pre like Chappelle and rock and bringing
those guys in pre-doing that stuff right
you know people would say when are you
going to get a HBO special that's right
that's how people would talk about it
and that would be the Pinnacle that'd be
like being in Vegas as a magician early
Arts it was still that was the that was
the bell of the ball that was the Bell
90s was Comedy Central 2000s was
definitely HBO even even 90s was like
still Carl in a rock but it was like but
but
umbrella so yes Comedy Central was a
thing that was like if you were huge it
was going to be huge for you right but
like that's where you kind of started
you know they had like Premium plan and
live at Gotham and yeah so then it was
like you were working towards that to
get to what an HBO special that was the
Pinnacle of it yeah and then you know
Netflix comes in and goes you know what
why don't we grab these guys because at
the time they wouldn't have done it
time
I don't think Chris Rock Chappelle and
Louis and Seinfeld and all the deals
that they made yeah right yeah no no it
was definitely like it was that was the
only spot that gave you whatever that
pedigree validation was just HBO yes
yeah now you could like look at somebody
like Lou and he's doing it completely
through his own Hub right well he was
one of I think he was one of the first
guys to do that where he was like he's
selling it on his side and yeah he's
like you know what I'm gonna do I'm
doing this my damn self yeah it was like
during that very there was a that period
of time where it's like you know digital
copy and then I remember doing like
deals with like remember like JTV or you
stream yeah yeah yeah and I would do
like you know my college you get three
dollars tonight we'd have one stationary
camera and you could pay to come into so
it was that there was a little period of
time when you were like oh wow it you
know if nothing else I don't need to do
a deal in Sharing in the profit with uh
streamer or network I can really you
know get a hundred percent of what I've
put into this thing as I listen to you
talk about this I realize part of the
the
drive for your success that you've had
over your lifetime now in Hollywood is
that you you're you seem to be on top of
the business part of it right well
probably more so now since of what is
what happened 100 yeah because like
because because you've you've mentioned
this a lot now it's like you know when
they're residuals knowing the deal so so
you're probably more on top of that more
than anyone else oh because of what
happened I've got an incredible group of
people and I'm like I'm in student mode
learning from great attorneys and stuff
as to like because right now a contract
is being written that two years from now
some of the language because of the tech
is going to change and you're going to
be stuck in language that they no longer
have to oversee because the word stream
has become something else right River
and that's how sag messed up okay that
that's so funny you say that because the
Screen Actors Guild they were to me they
were so arrogant thinking that we're
going to be on film forever and we're
going to cover film and then like nobody
uses film except for artsy [ __ ] right
you know what I mean yeah and so now we
you know they had to years had to go
before they finally figured out how to
do New Media yeah the language and the
language of like you know video versus
digital and all that you know you know
what I mean and a lot of people just
took advantage of the language yeah you
know right they'd buy the catalog and
then they go oh the artists that signed
this deal their language says uh VCR
tapes
you know what I mean it's like
they could get around paying you man
well here's you know I had a dumb deal I
I this is what I asked for I I asked for
well because I couldn't get more money I
was like well give me a thousand DVDs
for free okay because I was gonna take
them on the road
don't laugh at me
let me tell you something it gives me a
thousand of your DVS they didn't just
deliver anything in their catalog I wish
that would have been I think I could
have done better I think I could sell
those already got fingers
like the Matrix one and two no and it
was like literally I think I got this
deal I got I I got these DVDs three days
before no one watched DVDs anymore
we still have them I still have yeah
like 900 of them yeah in my closet right
so I mean you you try because in my mind
I thought you know you go on the road
and you sell them for twenty dollars
each that's what you did and it's like
if that that'd be twenty thousand
dollars that was that was exactly what I
mean so and then but like I say that's
how quickly technology moves right you
know but when it switched over and
that's why it's so important like I hope
people look at this example of what I've
put together to go
if in your own way maybe in a way I
haven't thought of if you can get a few
say Comics together and go man we all
chip in and it's just our budget and we
create a show that maybe highlights all
of us and you can hold on to it and get
with a place like a moment and there's a
lot more places now that are coming down
yeah yeah you do a small term lease and
by the way you can do a small term lease
and if you get numbers that are Bonkers
guess who's gonna call Netflix or apple
or they're gonna go may we have a lease
as well may we have a window now it
might be more paperwork but if you start
with that IP and you can own it for the
rest of your life at least you can
follow it you Watermark it with your
team with your legalese and you follow
it if it goes on did you package 400
people dude I'm here for you I'm here
for you now where were you I only had to
fail miserably
I had to be under Rock Bottom to to
really learn what I always wanted to
know in the first place because I am
kind of fascinated with the business
side of things as much just I love
having fun and being funny and do a
spectacle event moment you know in my
down time I really love learning the
vernacular and the understanding
I feel like I I see like cook Management
on the horizon cook
cook is probably better because I also
like I go through those moments where
it's like you ever be mentoring somebody
and you know that there's so many things
that they need to [ __ ] change and do
differently and they just need to learn
and they need to fall on their face and
they go what should I do Eric what do
you think should I and you're like how
do I tell this person to just suck for
like six years and then finally one day
they'll have a fit and when they have
the fit they'll go on stage from the
emotion of the fit and it'll start to
work
stand on how to be emotionally connected
listen man when somebody asks me like
hey I'm going to start doing comedy what
do you think start doing I just go I
just go get out of my face yeah you know
go do it right you know just go do it
because what do you want me to do I look
when they go should I start with like
Open Mic yeah what else is there before
that they want to skip
well now they do because they and they
want that great like one hit on a tick
tock or whatever a video that goes viral
and you're like yeah if you get 100
million hits good luck in the meetings
when they're like what else do you got
and you're like I don't have [ __ ]
anything because I'm an idiot I had one
good idea too early
I peeked before I even know where the
peak was no no you want the road you
want you TR you want the you want the
whole every [ __ ] low rung of the
ladder should you should hear this
like it's about to but it's about to
snap and you gotta live on those low
rungs if you want to get better and also
like just you know well I mean you still
have but you still you still have uh I
mean yeah you do because you perform all
the time so I know you still have the
thing to do stand-up comedy whatever
that thing is I love it I love it
because it's always because you're
growing and you're evolving in your
perspective now I can look back at 30
years now I'm taking the piss out of
myself out of my own opinions things
that I used to think were yeah yeah I
would die on the you know on the hill
yeah so it it's the evolution of comedy
and being being able to like be present
but now have some funny self-deprecating
hindsight and then Wonder like all right
what do what is the next thing that I
want to do after something like this you
know I don't know yet I I really don't
well the fact is you the fact that you
could just like you know enjoy the enjoy
it now I mean are you enjoying it now I
mean because I would say is like knowing
you is I'm not saying I know you a great
you know you know I don't know a lot but
I'm saying just there are interactions
yeah I would like to know like like are
you enjoying yourself finally you know
ready like really it was like 90s a lot
of fear even though fun right there's
always there's always fun in stand-up
there's always laughs and great
breakfast somewhere like at two in the
morning and all that so it's like can I
do it a lot of fear and then the early
2000s it was like Wow right the the
the dream come true moments
not really knowing how to manage all
that personally or professionally but it
was still fun and it was still all those
things you wanted and then I hit the
tens and I'm like I'm dealing with a lot
of personal strife and all those things
I get to Troublemaker in 15 I direct it
and right at that moment I'm like oh wow
like making presenting this how I wanted
myself to be seen I got really excited
in the last five well now seven years
with the pandemic have been
I'm happy because I'm away from all that
crazy [ __ ] I'm not caught up in the this
machine out here I'm not I'm not of it I
still participate in it very different
way more fun
um and so the last bunch of years it's
been more like me just being centered
happy and loving stand-up comedy like I
did at the very very start that's great
to hear and
mentioning the pandemic do you think
that the pandemic had a what was the
what part did it play in changing like
your perspective on yourself on life on
your on the business on your
relationships it made me just miss it
tremendously it made me miss it and I
and not just I never felt like I ever
took it for granted but when it felt
like it was maybe gone forever
and I was really like thinking about
like highlight moments even if they were
just simple hangs at the club man where
it's like oh wow all of us guilt tonight
we were you know everybody walked by can
I take a picture with all of you best
compliment hey can we all take a picture
together those are the best regular
nights of our life away from a big tour
as opposed to when they come in like
they give the camera to one person hey
can you take a picture of me and
I'm just kind of like okay I
remember like you know keep at it you
know just keep at it you're good too you
can't keep working yeah I hate that's
the one I hate yeah they come out they
see two people and they go oh my God
they were like oh yeah we liked you too
Patrice O'Neal had the funniest thing
about that ever because he used to you
know be back in New York back in Boston
and very early on he was the first one
of us to key into the you know getting
the you were good too one night if you
know anything about Patrice he was a
world-class ball buster yeah and if you
didn't understand why he was coming at
you the way he was you could be very
offended really quick one time a guy
gave Patrice the U2 do you mind if I get
physical with you for a second okay a
guy gave Patrice the U2 and tried to do
the what is that weird handshake where
it's not a proper handshake but we're
gonna we're gonna clasp hands like you
ever have somebody go and shake your
hands
and it's like what like we're holding
hands gonna run together for a minute
so
the YouTuber he wanted to be ready I'm
Patrice get the hello
this [ __ ] whacked this guy to
where he pulled it and was stunned and
walked away and Patrice said some more
Choice words but man it was the funniest
you two comeback yeah now he'd be
arrested for assault
he'd be canceled for assault being back
at the club's after honestly and even
though there was outside gigs and it was
a little wonky for a bit and it just um
when I got back into it I said um I'm
never going to not fully appreciate for
the rest of my life that I've gotten to
do this for a lot of my life yeah man I
I think that I had a different
perspective too I think I had a whole
different you know it was like I I cared
more about my relationships and uh you
know I ended up getting married and yeah
you know what I mean it was just like it
just I I had a more appreciation for
doing stand up and and how I was going
to approach it and just also I feel I I
learned like let me monetize my
personality in other ways too right yeah
cause your problem
yeah do podcasting do like you know
gaming yeah there's so many different
ways I felt like your identity really it
you know people know you for a lot of
things but I felt like you came out of
that moment you were doing it going into
it but really came out of that moment
it's like people knew you yes right
people knew you they knew that you were
important to other affiliations but they
also knew that you were important you
know solo yeah and this is great but
that's the thing that I feel like I
think everyone needed to learn coming
out of the pen yeah who's a crony who
needs a squad and who can like fly solo
and and you know create brand and
content and all that good stuff like you
know on their own and you were one of
those people but this is like again like
this is like now the new thing you know
this is this new business model now this
is like what you're saying like you know
owning your IP only have you know now
it's about hey you could do it with your
podcast because now now you're like
we're we are direct to Consumer now I
mean because here's what I think the
next
thing is going to be YouTube I think the
next YouTube's already big you know huge
it's huge already right and now YouTube
stories and all this stuff it's like
even better but what I'm saying is
Netflix didn't have the respect
before and then they got these
dignitaries of Comedy to do specials and
then it became like now people are
walking around like when am I going to
see you on Netflix okay right so they
got that the next one's gonna be YouTube
yeah and I hope that YouTube does
something take maybe takes a page out of
a few Comics I've seen in myself to
where it's like put a little bit it's a
it's a little more money and a little
more effort into creating a style a look
for the comic so that aesthetically it
it feels Beyond just you can listen to
jokes on a spot you can listen to
Somebody's audio anyway yeah yeah yeah
if you're gonna make me especially since
think about this you're watching all
these things that are so Dynamic on
television on streaming now and then it
hits a stand-up special and weirdly that
is now one of the most kind of
low-key things when stand-up used to
feel like the most dynamic thing you
could watch on TV it flipped right so
you got to have something like when
people see my special
it it still lives in three quarter it
has to the jokes are always going to
live and die there's nothing you could
do to make a joke funnier with a shot
but if it's lovely and there's a an
energy or like why did this person shoot
at a strip club why is this person at
the laundromat doing their special right
why is this person at the Symphony Hall
of the something that matches the tone
of the comic is sometimes I feel like
people are searching for things and
they're falling short right but it's got
to be organic it's gonna be organic yeah
but how you just talk about that is
interesting because do you think then
that YouTube is going to get into buying
specials business because what I meant
to say YouTube I meant to say like you
know you people are going to do it
themselves and then when they release it
on YouTube it's gonna be people are
gonna be like oh that's where I want to
watch Comedy right as opposed to but if
you think that you know because YouTube
could they so easily could be like hey
we want to produce this and make sure
it's high level quality I mean I I think
they're gonna I think
two deals it'll be either YouTube
produced right they'll come in and
they'll however that works hopefully not
perpetuity the one word that you don't
want in any contract but whatever that
deal is where they say like we will make
it and cultivate this for you versus I
think that more people being able to go
to them and and they will understand
that this is a one-year lease window and
we want them to stay here because
they're going to see the numbers they're
aggregating and they're going to get
then you want to do another year you
want to do I I hope that it's more
short-term uh you know IP from artists
to partner and then it reverts back
totally fair the only thing that's
different about comedy as opposed to say
music is like you know even with music
now because everything's streaming it's
like once you've seen the thing and this
is where you can see it
like before it was like you know they
could watch you on uh Comedy Central
right and then you're coming out with
that album and it's the only place they
can hear it to see it it's on that DVD
right on that CD that's been taken away
so
just having it out there or someplace
living is like is it do you think that's
the most important think about this
though what we're talking about is the
one place that things from other places
usually end up
um uh spliced up and excerpts is YouTube
yeah yeah so if YouTube's at the middle
of it we're you're not gonna go on
Netflix and see a random upload of uh so
if that place figures out a way to be
the most user-friendly in in short-term
leases so that people get their IP back
and hopefully they'll say but we handle
it well please stay with us
where my thing is like where would you
even go is my point like if you like
what I'm saying is that that's what I'm
saying like I feel like that's the last
stop is YouTube It's YouTube so I'm
saying you go to YouTube and they go
well hey we want to give you x amount of
dollars because we want to make sure
it's high quality and it's on YouTube
where else is it gonna go right are you
gonna I'm pulling it off YouTube
to do what well it's funny though
because it used to be that I think the
business model was somebody had it and
then distributed it so that their
Network could get more monetization
versus now the model is if it's on uh a
YouTube
as long as people are continuing to feed
those numbers they can get fresh new
advertising so it doesn't behoove them
to even want to go be on their own walls
the way yeah a syndication deal used to
be like oh let's get it to TBS that's
all no but with comedy now it's like
this now it's about getting it into
hotels right getting it on Delta
Airlines that's right like a great
company like um uh Universal's distrib
global distribution yeah unbelievable
they do an amazing job yes yes they're
on planes and hotels and yeah all those
places that when you're off the computer
somewhere else you've got content but
the question there would be like you
know this is so nerdy right now guys
[Laughter]
the question is put this whole part on
like double speed
it's just like it sounds like Charlie
Brown's teachers
no but then the question would be like
you have to ask yourself why are you
doing it uh you know that's just what's
your motivation are you doing it for
money are you doing it uh for
recognition exposure The Profit yes
exposure because because we've got to
pay your rent and of course everybody
wants to make listen if you have a great
comedy special or concert film or
whatever at the center in a place like a
YouTube then you can be smart enough to
figure out ways to merch and meet and
greet in a seminar and you can do a
bunch of other stuff around that you
know what I was gonna say man you know
what I really enjoyed when we when I
went on notes though that uh doing shows
with you yeah you know and uh and I
appreciate that I've I felt like you did
a little extra because I was there and I
appreciated that you know like because
we went on a private jet and we were
staying at the Four Seasons and you know
what I mean it was like it was just very
I think I did that for you no no but I'm
saying I don't know but I mean I don't I
would be going out of pocket here for
Erica no but I mean I know that like if
like if you have like your regular
opener you're not getting that kind of
treatment I want everybody and maybe
they do and that's great I consider you
a good friend I wanted to have an
experience that and I do this a lot I go
if this is the last blast for whatever
reason let's have a [ __ ] great time
with it it really will always figure out
a way to make a buck and do whatever I
got to do to like you know get ahead but
in those moments I felt like let's make
this really memorable let's look back on
this and go oh dude but I was gonna say
though what I really I saw what I liked
too when I was like amazed at is like
the that you were right there with your
meet and greet
before the show right like and it was
like guys I mean and it was like you you
I I was seeing like the evolution of
your fans too like they've stuck around
right you know because your fans are now
like yeah yeah your fans are like you
know it's like a Duty's like 48. that's
right you know he's 52 now and he's like
hey buddy yeah yeah he's doing the
fingers and he's like this is my wife
and here's my 19 year old son second
wife yeah yeah and we've loved you in
like it's like man how does that like
how does that feel to like yeah you know
what I mean it's like it's like you know
my fans I've grown up I always wanted to
grow up with a generation of Comedy fans
I accomplished that but then the kids
that are like they didn't know my
stand-up they saw employee of the month
they saw Dan in Real Life they saw
something side item and then they come
to see oh you know and we knew you did
stand up and the cool thing is you know
this about me like when I'm going on
stage to do a show especially on the
road I I'm it's not like oh we're just
going to see a good comedy show so when
I knew that next generation was there
and their parents like watch this and
and I go up on stage to just like light
it up to where they go oh we like the
employee we didn't even know the comedy
was this good we thought it was going to
be like an homage to Zach from Employee
of the Month uh you know so that's
interesting that yeah I like that
because I feel the same way about like
you always want the challenge oh man
yeah you always you always want to be
like hey you want to exceed the
expectation people come out they know
they're you're funny they're gonna go ah
we know Eric's gonna give a great show
but when you put that little bit of
extra effort whether it's meeting them
or something in your show that lets them
know wow like this wasn't a repeat of
the last time he was here he really
worked on new [ __ ] yeah and gave us a
whole new show and you do a lot of great
band you're always in the moment and
what's great about that kind of Comedy I
always try to keep a piece of that is
it's always a show for you and you feel
it and when you leave you're like that's
never going to happen again yeah yeah so
we're in it we're in good shape Manda
you know yeah you know and it's like I
just like it's funny because I just did
La Jolla again uh at La Jolla Comedy
Store yeah it was like great spot it was
great but I was just there and so like
knowing that I was gonna go there really
put some pressure on myself because I
was like oh I gotta work on this because
now I'm working on this marriage
material and like you know and it's in
my own way and I was like I like that I
like when people come and go man I saw
you like however many months ago when
this is all new you know so it's like
that or if they see you again and you've
worked on the bit and they go ah we saw
that when it was new and it was all
right yeah yeah and now it's it's
crushing it's like you know I think that
it's always incumbent of a comic going
on the road to give your fans something
I never want them to go like oh that was
like that was good that was a good show
it's like no give them something that
really makes him feel like man we that's
a can't miss sure and it's probably like
I'm not saying it's hard for you that's
not the words I'm trying to use but what
I'm saying is you have the experience of
being like you know at the top of the
food chain of like I remember like you
coming out in the Laugh Factory back in
the day and I saw this kid in a crowd he
was like oh my God I can't believe it's
Dane Cook you know so like you know so
like how does that feel to be like all
right so maybe it's not that anymore
sometimes and sometimes it is sometimes
it's not do you feel that does it bother
you how like what how do you deal with
it there was never a feeling of like it
had to be that level because I also grew
up you know growing up I love Club
comedy I I would watch um uh um The
Improv show uh you know comedy on the
road or whatever those things evening at
The Improv and all those and I and I
knew that stand up was best consumed in
a you know a comedy seller type place
you know like you know low ceilings and
I I the same way I had such a
uh respect for broadcasting because my
dad had done a lot of like I knew what
real broadcasting was based on what my
father taught me versus like just a
superstar who happens to have a mic in
their hand and so when all that stuff
started like 150 Arenas then turned into
like all right now I'm gonna do a great
theater run or I'm doing Club you know
clubs yeah yeah for me what that felt
like was whether it's a large-scale gig
or something that's more intimate it
kind of felt like the life of like um
like the Rolling Stones will play a cool
[ __ ] hole in the wall and blow the
doors off and if a big gig comes along
you want to see the Rolling Stones and a
huge event you go do that it's great you
know so I I never yeah no no I never
looked at it and said it's got us nobody
would want to maintain those are fun but
maintaining that level doesn't feel like
stand up when you're with a theater or a
club full of people where you can take
really take your time and get into like
yeah how you're feeling about that it's
a whole different kind of show I mean
that's the truth or you're you know
because you're a true calm make and so I
was going to say too is like you also
have seen like you know maybe someone
that you really admire and you see him
on stage just eating [ __ ] and you know
that that's part of Comedy that you know
that there's super highs and there's
super lows right and we're trying to
find some consistency but there's still
highs and lows even within that exactly
if you came to me tomorrow and said hey
we're doing a uh and friends at Madison
Square Garden or some Arena it's like
dude yeah I'd be there let's blow the
doors off the place let's make it an
event but if you said to me oh we're
doing like a cool little theater tours
10 theaters on the west coast it's like
that's just as fun yeah it's just as
meaningful you know especially the fans
will say to you and I can't tell you how
many fans said to me uh you know years
after doing just arenas for like a good
five year run I like seeing you man
where I can really hear everything and
it's like wow they're a part of it yeah
they like they were like we like the
event but this feels like we can
actually understand what you're saying
and it's not just a spectacle it's
actually like a person talking to us you
know
um I really really there's some I think
maybe it's because we're at your house
right okay yeah which it's looking
really nice man
I feel I I think that you're you're in a
different place and I really I like it
yeah yeah I feel good man yeah I think I
think you feel good I know you're
engaged yes I am congratulations thank
you man to both of us man yeah we came
out
so I feel like um I like that you know I
mean because like you've had your ups
and downs you've had your you know
you've had people you know I think no
one's I don't I I think no one has loves
love Been Loved more or hated more than
you probably you know what I mean yeah
like just to have that well except for
like maybe somebody's you know in this
new era of like people you know well now
you're love hated in like uh 48-hour
period and everybody yeah forgets but I
think that you've had this thing and I
say I feel like you're at a cool place
now and I like it and so where can
people find the special so right now
what we're doing is above it all is on
moment dot Co forward slash Dane Cook I
mean you can go to danecook.com and it's
just going to jail yeah let's go there
right so
but but the whole idea with moment in
like again giving Andrew Schultz's
flowers he had I've been talking to them
and then he did a special through there
and it was so such an example of this is
the way people want your special in
their pocket they want to be able to get
you know cool stuff there's you know
merge bundles all the stuff that comes
with like an exciting drop but to be
able to do it and then say now I'm gonna
present it maybe a month later I've
already got a place that I want to go
after that's reached out and said we'd
love to do a window and I'm like wow
this idea of like being Rogue and being
random and hitting different Windows
different places where people consume
that may not be a streamer or even an
internet okay funny you mentioned Andrew
Schultz because it's it's it's weird
because you guys
come from different to come to different
places doing the same thing and that's
what's great about it right because
Andrew I feel like maybe he didn't get
the the the breaks that he wanted like
he didn't uh you know like Hollywood
wasn't come crawling the comedy clubs
were like I don't know about this guy
right and he was like you know what I
want to get my own fans I'm gonna do
this my own way and then he did that and
now you know he's carved a niche for
himself that he's decided I don't need
this recognition from these other things
and so kudos to him for that and cut to
somebody that like yourself who did get
the recognition you you came up in a
traditional way right and then you you
hit the Pinnacle of it and now you hear
finding the next way to do it exactly
and you know what in doing it in a way
that complementary to what I did at the
beginning guys now like Andrew are doing
now and looking and saying there's great
ways to be a hybrid you can still be a
showman but you can be business-minded
and say you know what there's a way to
reach way more fans in way more
interesting ways and places if I keep
the energy behind the content instead of
just saying put it on your page
somewhere yeah and then they don't
really they're not caring about they
care about their subscriptions but
they're not calling you going hey you
know what we should do we should do this
today here's a great promo and you'll
never get that phone call once you
partner up with yeah they have it yeah
that's it they just want it and be able
to say we got it in their mind they're
just kind of like well hey we're doing
you a favor right now Schultz is
probably somewhere going now I can do
this now my phone's ringing that might
be an interesting Avenue I never thought
about that and he can explore several
windows before he chooses to probably
make a bigger deal somewhere where you
know well then finally they go and now
and how about this yeah well the the
cool thing would be with with this
generation if they if they decide to go
I'm good
you know the big streamers call like hey
we want to know like I'm good I got I'm
I have so many fans yeah like you know
that's that's that you know do you know
how many
um
kids under the age of 25
are watching Tick Tock I know this it's
just unbelievable 95 yeah only Tick Tock
that's it they're not they say do you
watch TV they're like
I don't know my parents watch TV and TV
my TVs my TV's on the go because I'm on
the go because I'm going to my next cool
thing where I'm gonna take video I'm
going to be you know this next
generation is living in a moment all the
time Snapchat's another one man right
Snapchats it's they're here it's the
huge numbers five percent and then uh
like of that number it's like 88r
um just jumping over to YouTube when
they want to watch long form whatever
that might be and long form is like so
eight minutes so did anybody who's on
the come up going like what does all
this mean for me it means come up with
your stuff
get it spliced up and it can be a
shorter piece of the the long show and
start exploiting yourself through these
Avenues and build your fan base the same
way Andrew or myself or even people
before the internet did it which is like
meet people wherever you can meet them
yeah let them get to know you that's
what you did the podcast was a way to
know Eric's not just from Workaholics
the funny guy who does it he he went
from in some ways being a crony of Adam
in that team to being out front with
your own very strong career so be that
be this yeah well you know we I'm still
trying to be that
yeah you read the play next time take me
[ __ ]
oh yeah I'll rent the planet it'll be
like we'll be you mean the middle seat
on the Southwest flight
get you there so uh but hopefully we'll
see you may you know do some more shows
with this guy we'll be out there with
some place but check out make sure you
go to danecook.com or the other one yeah
moment.co moment.co Dane Cook to check
out his new special shot right here
above it all above it all you know and
that's a great name for it too yeah
you're finally above it all yeah man
it's a lot of symbolic It's the funniest
stuff that I put together over
um a five-year period since troublemaker
and the fact that Marty culner directed
it and really brought the best out of me
over two great nights here so hope you
guys have a lot of laughs yeah so make
sure you know make sure you check that
out I got all the information all those
links and everything will be right there
we get it I know I know we get it we
know this is the point of it man just
want to do this you know I love you know
what I love about this podcast right now
it's like we started in the day and now
it's like come down to the night you
know what I mean like it's like it's
like I'm doing some sort of artsy fartsy
thing right here so fade out with jazz
music yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what
I probably will uh but anyways guys uh
thanks Dane for being on thanks for
having me here to do this and now we are
going to dinner bye see you guys
foreign